ni pro se trouve à 300 km de Mario Paul
bien loin des combats c'est ici qui est
venu se réfugier la chef de la police de
la ville la capitaine
puis à la mi-mars l'enfer commence
les voitures ont été détruites par un
tank il y a eu deux morts
les Russes ont mis fin aux fonctions des
quelques 300 policiers qui n'avaient
plus qu'une chose à faire s'évader pour
éviter d'autres ennuis son père est
resté là-bas
sous les tirs d'artillerie avec un
collègue il trouve une voiture en état
de marche mais sans vitre et c'est le
parcours du combattant à travers une
vingtaine de contrôle russe destinés à
ralentir la caravane
peu d'habitants parviennent à sortir de
Mario Paul vers l'Ukraine par contre les
Russes offrent les autobus vers la
Russie n'ayant pas d'autre choix
beaucoup de gens acceptent le martyre de
Mario Paul continue on parle de 20000
morts
par la taille de la fosse commune que
les rues sont creusées sur ces images
satellites 300 mètres carrés on les
soupçonne de vouloir camoufler des
massacres de civils mais la résistance
ukrainienne continue dans le dernier
bastion la Syrie azowstael pilonnée
impitoyablement elle a chaque jour des
nouvelles à l'intérieur mais plus il
résiste plus l'armée russe enregistre
des pertes elle est sûre que l'armée
ukrainienne est très forte patriote
jusqu'au bout des ongles avec une bague
gravée du nom de Mario Paul elle a
l'intention d'y retourner dans la police
quand tout sera terminé Jean-Michel
Leprince Radio-Canada ni pro